gonna how is europe doing in terms of
the digital agenda
not good enough
and that's good
because if this was the best we could do
it would be quite hopeless
we can do a lot better
on on fiber
rather well in a number of countries but
still not good enough
regarding mobile broadband not at all as
good as it should be
and for me these two things are very
closely linked together because the
development of the new services are very
much
dependent on the development of the
mobile broadband
while the fixed
lines the fiber
will provide the stability for all the
different services we want to do so they
are very closely connected but we are
not transforming enough we are not
changing enough and and we need to do
that and
i think the only key to that is that we
must be
much better on securing that we have the
fiber connections and the coverage that
we need to have because that is a
precondition for the development of the
mobile service be it wi-fi or be it
mobile broadband or whatever
because people are already talking about
5g that's coming along
at
a fast pace how do you see that
impacting on fiber
i think 5g will mean an
acceleration of the traffic
because it will mean
acceleration of all the new services
you can
have
driver
vehicles without a driver
which requires a lot of traffic in the
net
and the fixed flat as well as under in
different mobile applications
and you can have a medical services you
will have all this machine to machine
and well the internet of everything and
the internet of everything will require
everything
fiber and mobile broadband and
my main messages
never fall into the trap that
the mobile broadband is another thing
that the fixed and the fixed is another
thing that they're mobile they are
closely dependent on each other not only
for their basic
and fundamental traffic but also for the
development of the services
presuming that we eventually get this
right and we all move forward in europe
how do you see the relationship between
the ict industry and european business
developing what are going to be the
benefits so my view is that we will talk
about ict in the future
as we today are talking about
electricity
as a very normal phenomenon
i mean it is some decades ago when we
looked upon the ict people as people in
wild coats being rather mysterious in a
special department in the in the company
or
etc
now it is distributed and
among us all but we still tend to talk
about the digital sector
in the next
10 years to come
we will have no digital sector because
our society will be based on the digital
technologies as electricity has been for
quite a while so i think we are which is
a paradoxical thing we are entering a
phase of normalization
where the
internet and the very many applications
will form the structure of our economy
and society and that means that we need
to be in the lead
in this development because otherwise we
will not be in the lead of the economic
development
well let's hope we can get into that
late position thank you very much for
joining us and giving us insight into
what you feel the issues are
thank you very much